belőlem is egy remek nárcisztikus
várhatott volna, egy manipulatív, egy
gázlángozó, egy egy ragadozó. Ez nagyon
jó, hogy megemítetted, hogy senki nem
gonosznak születik. Így fogalmaztad,
mert több kommentárő pont ezt kérdezte,
hogy ez genetikailag örökölhető-e. És ez
szerencsére mármint utána jártam, és én
is így így gondolom, és remélem, hogy te
is egyetértesz, hogy ez nem genetikai
betegség. Ez nem nem lehet az, hogy
édesapám az volt, és akkor lehet, hogy
bennem is megvannak a mindenkiben meg
van a hajland és bennem is megvan. És
emlékszem, ahogy az egyetemista éveim
első évében történt az a fordulat. Ha
nem fordul, akkor meg az életem, akkor
belőlem is egy remek nárcisztikus
várhatott volna. Egy manipulatív, egy
gázlángozó, egy egy ragadozó.
لا